Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
Seo miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao dành
cho người mới bắt đầu được thực hiện
trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số 7
hành Tìm kiếm với lúc cấp và hát nó cấp
trước khi đi vào bài số 7 nhưng không
giải bài tập hôm trước là bài thơ 6 khác
hành xử lý chuỗi nhé Ok câu hỏi của bài
số 6 là gì ạ Ở đây mình có tên đầy đủ
bây giờ mình cần tách họ và tên thì với
cái trường hợp họ thì dễ rồi Đúng Hầu
như các bạn sẽ làm được nhá các bạn sẽ
bằng đấy ạ thì để cách họ tức là nằm ở
bên cây trái Đúng không các bạn sử dụng
các hạt lép đấy gọn sẽ cứng cáp thì cái
ô đầu tiên mà các bạn cần tách là diện
là cái tên đầy đủ đây tức là ok 4 đúng ạ
phải tiếp theo là diện là cái số kí tự
các bạn thường tách đúng ạ Mà cái số kí
tự các bạn cách là rẻ các bạn thân xác
định các số ký tự cần tách bằng cách là
các bạn sẽ tìm cái vị trí cái dấu cách
đầu tiên của Cái ô này đúng ạ Đấy mà dị
các vị trí của cái dấu cách nó sẽ khác
nhau
Em thuộc vào tên đúng không để tìm được
cái vị trí của cái dấu cách đầu tiên gặp
có thể dùng cái hàng file Và Hành Sơn
nhá lại Ví dụ mình dùng cái hòm file đi
đây thì thành phần đầu tiên của cây hồng
file là điện cái Tech mà mình cần tìm
đúng không có sẽ mở kẹp ra các bạn hãy
nêu cách tức là việc mình cần tìm cái
dấu cách đúng không phẩy trong cái ôm
nào trong cái otn đầy đủ đây chắc là ob4
đúng không vào mình tìm thấy cái vị trí
đầu tiên thì bạn không cần nhập các tham
số cuối cùng nhá các bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
bạ thì nó sẽ hiểu là tìm từ vị trí đầu
tiên đấy sau khi mà cái Hàn file này thì
nó sẽ tìm được cái vị trí dấu cách rồi
đúng không thì các bạn phải - 1 cơ đấy
Tại vì gì mình sẽ lấy trước cái vị trí
du khách không Ví dụ ở đây là mình lấy
cái chữ nguyễn Tức là mình đến cái chữ N
thấp vậy thôi bằng cái dấu cách thì mình
không lấy đúng không đấy thì cậu phải -
1 lại cậu xe rẻ các bạn sẽ đóng cặp đôi
lại các em tơ đấy gọi thấy chứ chỉ như
vậy Ở đây mình đã tách được cái phần họ
ở Nga họ sẽ đổ vào đây đấy thì như vậy Ở
đây mình sẽ lấy được toàn bộ các cái họ
của các bạn này đúng không ạ
Ừ để lấy được tên nhá thì có rất là
nhiều cách để lấy được tên nhưng mà
thông thường các cách đấy rất là dài thì
hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn một
cách rất là đơn giản thì các thuật toán
của mình nhận diện tất cả các dấu cách ở
đây này mình sẽ tăng lên thành 100 số
cách này nhá Đấy sau đó mình sẽ lấy phải
100 ký tự thì đảm bảo chắc chắn là dẹp
lấy được cái tên không ạ thì thông
thường cái tên của mình thì tối đa là 8
1 9 thứ tự do đúng không Thì mình lấy
100 là lấy gọi là dự phòng đấy thì sau
khi mình lấy 100 người mình sẽ dùng cái
hàng chim Để mình gọi lại đúng không đấy
thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ nhân cái dấu
cách này lên 100 lần bằng cách để mình
sẽ kết hợp với hàng xuất thích cu vào
cái Hàn việc và cái hàng Red đây nhá Ở
đầu tiên mình sẽ thiện mình nhân cái dấu
cách nhưng 100 lần nhá lại ví dụ là việc
ngân số cách đây mình sẽ tách ra thành
các khách hàng riêng để gọn hiểu này
nhân cái dấu cách thành 100 lần đúng
không Để mình viết ra đây để chọn dễ
hiểu rồi cậu sẽ bằng bằng cách sắp xếp
chim
vì thế các thành phần đầu tiên của shop
tung là cái chỗ này đúng không Đấy phải
đâu Tech là diệt Kotex các bạn mở két ra
các đánh dấu cách các bạn đâu mà cái
vàng tức là việc cái chuỗi mà mình cần
nhân lên là cái dấu cách đúng không phải
cái lưu Tech là Rịa con sẽ dùng cái hàng
grab đời cẩn một cái xuống và các ấn top
nhá Bạn mở cửa phép ra các bạn đừng có
cách cho bạn đâu có chép và đúng không
phải mình xin dâng cái dấu cạnh nhảy lên
100 lần rồi các bạn sẽ đóng đóng ngoặc
đơn như vậy Mình đóng ngoặc đơn Để mình
xong các em ghét vậy thì tức là diện
mình sẽ thay cái dấu cách thì mình sẽ
bằng 100 lần cái dấu cách rất là mình sẽ
nhân cái dấu cách đây 100 lần đúng không
Đấy cái tham số cuối cùng là việc mình
cho bỏ trống nhá Đấy cứ là tất cả các
dấu cách trong cái chỗ này nó sẽ được
nhân lên 100 lần với bọn em tôi cho mình
đấy còn thấy cho đây rồi cách rất là dài
để Nguyễn Thị Ngân ở đây này Đấy tiếp
theo mình sẽ dùng cái hàm dai nhá lại
cảm like để mình sẽ mình lấy phải 100 ký
tự đi các bạn sẽ bằng đấy ạ Các bạn sẽ
bằng cái hàm right i
A và các bạn cần tác chính là cái ô mà
sau khi đoạn nhân giống khách lên đúng
không phải 100 họ sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn thể
gọi enter thì như vậy còn thấy nó sẽ lấy
được cái chữ tâm và địa trước cái chữ
tâm này là rất là nhiều dấu cách cái chữ
tâm này là diện nó có 3 từ đúng không
cho nên nó sẽ còn 97 ví dụ khách nữa rồi
cuối cùng với dân dùng cái hàng chim lại
các siêu thị ở đây mình chụp bằng này
chim gọi ấn pháp của cái ô và sau khi
bạn lấy phải Đây nha Còn enter đấy nó sẽ
được về cái chữ tâm Các bạn thấy đấy Ở
đây mình đã giải thích cho bạn các cái
Hà mà mình làm nhé Mình diễn giải từng
bước một cho gọn dễ hiểu này ở đây mình
sẽ làm luôn mình sẽ lâm hàm nhá đấy Họ
sẽ bằng bằng chim chim của mở ngoặc gọi
xem dùng cái Android Đúng không Đây cái
hàng dai của gì của cái sắp chiếu ở đây
này cái tách ở đây chính là dịp chính là
cái cách ban đầu đây này phải âu tách
thì các bạn xem mở ngoặc kép ra bạn đánh
dấu cách chọn đóng ngoặc kép vàng đấy
cậu phải cái newtech là gì nhỉ
anh rep lại quả rượu mở két cho cách
đóng ngoặc kép phải các mình sẽ một nhân
100 lần với số cắt Nên uống các bạn sẽ
đóng mọc lại sau khi hợp này ta sẽ đóng
ngoặc lại để xong cái hàng sắt yêu đúng
không phải cái số ký tự mà có cần lấy là
gì thì cứ lấy 100 ký tự của cái hàng
like rồi đấy các bạn xem đóng ngoặc đơn
để xong cao ra bạn đóng ngoặc đơn lại
xong nè chim đấy này thấy rất là nắng
Đấy mình đã tìm được cái học tên ở đây
là tân rồi đấy vẫn thích đút vào đây
Okay khá là hai cái này rất là ngắn nhá
Nếu như bạn tham khảo trên mạng thì nó
rất là nhiều hàm phức tạp đúng không Thì
đây Mình chỉ dùng 4 làm với hàm chim và
like Sub Team hàng Red nhưng mà cái cú
pháp của nó rất là ngắn nhá Ok như vậy
mình đã xong cái câu hỏi của bài tập số
6 nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ vào bài số 7 là
cái hành Tìm kiếm Vlookup hlookup các
chú ý mình sẽ đẻ cái link tải file của
cái bài số 7 này trong phần mô tả cái
dưới video tốt nhất là các bạn tải về
các bạn vừa theo dõi
Ừ Nếu như các bạn không biết cách tải về
thì bạn có thể theo dõi các bài đầu tiên
mình đã hướng dẫn chi tiết cách để các
bạn tải file thực hành về nhá Bây giờ
mình sẽ mở cái file của bài tập hôm nay
các bạn chú ý nhé cái hàm Vlookup và cái
hàm hlookup là một trong những hàm quan
trọng nhất của Excel đặc biệt là w khi
các bạn đi làm thì Hầu như các bạn dùng
w cấp rất là nhiều khác nó cấp thì dùng
rất là hạn chế thôi Và nếu như mà có
thành khảo vui Cốc Cốc này thì hầu như
là công việc của bạn sẽ nhẹ đi rất là
nhiều đấy lại thịt cọ Thúy Nga ở đây
mình đã giới thiệu cú pháp của các hàm
Vlookup rồi đúng không ạ Cái hàm Vlookup
nó sẽ gồm 4 thành phần đầu tiên là cái
lúc cấp value Tức là cái giá trị mà con
cần dò tìm đây cái thứ hai là cái thai
của orc Tức là cái bảng các bạn cần tìm
tức là bạn tìm kiếm ở đâu đấy và cái thứ
ba là lớn như bạn tìm thấy cái giá trị
lấy rồi
ở cột mà toàn cần lấy kết quả là cái cột
thứ mấy và cái tham số cuối cùng là các
bạn cần tìm kiếm chính xác hay là không
Chính xác đấy và cái hòm help cũng gọi
nhá cái hào hát lúc cấp thì nó giống hệt
với cả cái lúc cấp nó chỉ khác nhau là
gì ạ Kết bảng giá trị giò này cái
Vlookup thì cái bảng giá trị do nó sẽ
được bố trí theo cột là bơ Tây cổ đại
ghê là ở đây là vertical trong khi cái
hàm hát lúc các bệnh Thì cái bảng giá
trị do đó lại được bố trí theo hàng nha
Đó là ho oriental đấy thì ở đây mình sẽ
làm ví dụ cho bạn hiểu nhé Ở đây mình sẽ
có hai cái ví dụ về Vlookup và hlookup
đây thì ở đây còn chửi nhá ở đây mình sẽ
phê lúc cấp là gì ạ Tức là mình có cái
họ tên được bố trí theo chiều dọc tức là
do cột lại cho lên mình sẽ dùng Vlookup
còn trong cái ví dụ Haruka ở đây thì cái
họ tên ở đây này lại được bố trí tiêu
hàng để tức là theo cái chiều nha Cho
nên mình phải dùng hát gấp vậy thì các
bạn sẽ tích vào đây đầu tiên mình sẽ
dùng cái Vlookup trước nhá các bạn sẽ
tích và cái ô tô
ở miền Nam các bạn sẽ bằng bằng viên lúc
cấp để cá Tấn tác vào này thì cách thành
phần đầu tiên là cái giá trị trọn thần
tìm đúng không Tức là mình cần tìm thấy
ông Võ Quốc Việt đây này Đấy khoán phải
này cái thành phần thứ hai là cái thay
bố ơi Tức là cái bảng giá trị rò Tức là
mình cần tìm thấy ông Võ Quốc Việt ở đâu
mình cần tìm ở cái vùng giá trị ở đây
đúng ạ đấy các bạn phải các thành phần
thứ ba là gì Tôi là sau khi mình tìm
được cái ông Võ Quốc gia này rồi thì
mình lấy cái thông tin gì đây giả sử
mình tìm được cái ông có Quốc Việt ở đây
nhá Đấy thì mình cần lấy cái thông tin
gì ở đây nó yêu cầu là mình cần tìm điện
thoại đúng không Thì mình xem cái ông Võ
Quốc Việt thì điện thoại nó làm ở cuộn
thứ mấy đây đầu tiên là họ tên là cuộc
thứ nhất này thành phố là cụ thứ hai và
cái điện thoại là cụ thứ ba đúng không
Thì ở đây cái cục trả về là cuộc số 3
phẩy thành phần cuối cùng ở đây mình cần
tìm là gì mình cần tìm kiếm chính xác
nhá thì lát nữa cái phần mà tìm kiếm
không chính xác là tìm kiếm tương đối
thì mình sẽ sang cái sim bên cạnh này là
k
em sau nhé Thì ở đây mình cần tìm chính
xác thì bạn gõ khô hoặc là gõ không nhá
Đây phone thì tương ứng với không có họ
sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại lại gọi enter lại
vẫn thấy chứ như vậy điện thoại của bạn
Võ Quốc Việt ở đây là điện 0985 này 22 4
5 6 năm rồi bây giờ sửa mình thay cái Võ
Quốc Việt bằng gì bằng cái vặn Nguyễn
Văn Ba này đi Hãy chọn tích vào đây con
đó là Diện Nguyễn Văn Thoại enter đấy
bạn thấy cho cái điện thoại này thay đổi
rồi bây giờ giả sử các bạn Nguyễn Văn
Ban này mình gõ vào gái xem có lại inter
đấy Con gì cho Nếu như mà cái tên mà nó
không tìm thấy thì nó sẽ báo về cái kết
quả gót oval các bạn chuối nhà nhiều khi
các bạn tìm nghị các bạn thấy nó Vidal
này không phải là lỗi đâu Tức là các bạn
dù hàng rất là đúng nhưng mà do cái giá
trị các bạn tìm kiếm nó không có trong
cái bảng giá trị dò cho nên nó sẽ trả về
kết quả là lót Vâng ở đây đó các bạn chú
ý là như vậy nhá ở đây Mình sẽ lưu lại
như vậy nếu như nó tìm thấy nó sẽ trả về
kết quả đây à
cho sức chuối cho mình nhá cái hàm
Vlookup này là gì ạ Cái giá trị các bạn
tìm kiếm ở đây này Ở đây lớn như cạn thì
họ tên nhá Thì cái bảng giá trị dò các
bạn phải tìm cái họ tên đầu tiên đấy Bây
giờ giả sử với họ tên đấy nó không phải
nằm ở đây mà nó làm ở cái phần thành phố
này nhé Bây giờ bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái phần
thành phố này Đấy cận kéo sang đây Bạn
giữ phím ship cho mình nhá sau này mình
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn một số các thủ
thuật về cái việc mà di chuyển này sau
nhá các bạn rất hiếm ship nhá Đợi khi mà
nó có anh gạch dọc như thế này được thì
các bạn sẽ bỏ cái thiệt trái ra và các
bạn bỏ tiền ship đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa
cái này đi nha nếu như mà anh để tìm
điện thoại lúc này thì các bạn lại phải
làm lại nhà các bạn sẽ bằng với lúc cấp
này các bạn phát nhá thì cái Thành Phần
đầu tiên là cái giá trị do thì vẫn là
cái ông Nguyễn Văn Ban này đúng không
phẩy và Rịa cái thành phần thứ hai là
bảng giá trị giò thịt các bạn thôi nhá ở
đây mình tìm họ tên đúng không cho lên
cái bảng giá trị do các bạn phải bôi đen
từ cái sân họ tên đây tức là cái cột đầu
tiên của cái bảng giá trị do nó
thì nó phải chứa cái họ tên mà mình cần
tìm đấy cần phải này thì lúc này cái
điện thoại ở đây có phải là làm ở cuộn
thứ hai các bạn tính từ cái cột họ tên ở
đây cơ 12 đấy còn phẩy hai hỏi bạn phải
không các bạn enter thì lúc này nó mới
ra thôi Còn nếu như mà diện các bạn cái
bảng giá trị rò đây không phải là từ
thiện từ cột C mà các bạn hãy tìm từ cột
bê nhé ví dụ mình thay cái C này bằng B
Các bạn thấy chứ lúc này nó sẽ bôi đậm
thử cột bê và giả sử mình tìm ở cây số 3
về với cái câu trả lời thứ ba Các em Thơ
thì nó sẽ báo lỗi nhanh đấy Tại vì gì ạ
Cái giá trị mà các bạn tìm ở đây là cái
họ tên thì cái bảng giá trị do các bạn
phải bôi đen từ cái phần họ tên đó đấy
là cái đặc biệt nghĩ là như vậy nhé Ở
đây mình đã có một số ghi chú mình nốt
lại rồi nhé tiếp theo là mình sẽ giới
thiệu về cái hòm hát lúc cấp thì cái hàm
hát nước cấp giống hệt cái hàm Vlookup
thôi cú pháp nó giống hệt nhau nhưng nó
chỉ khác là thực hiện là cái bảng giá
trị giỏ nó sẽ được bố trí theo hàng
ngang lại ở đây mình sẽ bằng luôn là hát
lúc cấp các bạn đánh tát nhá thì
ở trên là giá trị giò vẫn là cái ông họ
tên ở đây ví dụ ở đây là Nguyễn Duy
Dương đúng không cần phải lại cái thành
phần thứ hai là bảng giá trị dò lại vẫn
là cái gì họ tên rồi đấy hãy gọi chú ý
nhé Ở đây mình cần tìm cái Nguyễn Duy
Dương cho nên khách hàng đầu tiên nó
phải chứa cái tên lại ở đây cái hàng đầu
tiên hàng số 12 đúng không Đấy nó phải
chứa cái tên này phẩm tiếp theo là gì
anh cái hàng trả về vì ở đây là hát lúc
cấp đúng không là tìm kiếm cho hàng mà
thịt xa hàng trả về Bây giờ mình cần tìm
điện thoại đúng không Thì cái hàng của
mình là dễ từ cái hàng Họ tên Đây là một
này thằng Thành phố là hay và cái hàng
điện thoại là hành số 3 đúng không phẩy
3 phẩy không có sóng hoặc lại xong Hà
lúc cho bạn enter đấy thì như vậy mình
sẽ xong được là cái diện cái điện thoại
của bạn Nguyễn Duy Dương bây giờ giả sử
mình không phải là tìm điện thoại đi
đúng không mà mình tìm là lương đi chẳng
ở đây mình là Tiền lương lại thì lương ở
đây lại hàng trả về là hằng số mấy họ
tên là một này thành phố là hai điện
thoại là ba ngày tuyển dụng 4 và lương
là năm
ở đây thì cái hàng giả về sẽ là hằng số
5 các loại enter đây như vậy đây là
lương thì cái hành với laptop cũng vậy
nha mình quay lại cái hành với lúc có
một tí bây giờ mình thích bước vào đây
mình sửa là gì thì chắc tìm từ cái cột C
các bạn enter đây Thì như vậy là gì ạ
Cái điện thoại là cái cái điện thoại bạn
kích đúp vào đây và số ba đây mình sẽ xử
lý số 2 Đấy nó sẽ ra là điện thoại đúng
không Bây giờ giả sử mình không phải là
tìm điện thoại mà tìm ngày tuyển dụng
lên đúng không ngày tuyển dụng nhé lại
ví dụ này tuyển dụng thịt cách cột ngày
tuyển dụng là Rịa các bạn tính từ cái họ
tên này nhá họ tên là một điện thoại là
hai này chuyển nhượng là ba đúng không
Thì bạn Tĩnh bước vào đây Bạn sửa số 2
đường số 3 đấy thì nó sẽ ra là ngày sử
dụng Còn nếu như mà các bạn thay số 3 và
số 4 quả trứng nước và còn sửa số 4 là
các bạn enter đấy thì nó sẽ ra là diện
là lương các bạn đổi định dạng nhá bạn
sẽ vào cái thẻ hôm các bạn tích và cái
dấu phẩy lại thì nó sẽ ra là lương đây
của bạn diễn Nguyễn Văn Ba là lương thì
7 9 2 8 4 rồi bây giờ ví dụ mình thay
bằng gì ạ
Lê Hoàng Bảo chị nhé mình sửa thì Hoàng
Bà chị này gọi enter đây như vậy là gì ạ
lương của bạn Hoàng bảo chị này là 61800
tháng 3 Đây là cách sử dụng của hàng
Vlookup và hlookup nhá Ok mình sẽ sang
một cái ví dụ là gì ạ phê lúc cấp mà tìm
tương đối thì lúc đấy toàn chú ý nhá cái
hàm Vlookup ở đây này còn tích vào đây
hoặc kích vào đây bạn thấy là thì lúc
này là rẽ cái giá trị Cuối Cùng Ở đây là
cái phạm vi Tìm kiếm mình bằng không
đúng không Thì khi nào thì mình dùng cái
phạm vi Tìm kiếm bằng một lại các bạn
xanh này còn dùng cái một ở đấy trong
các trường hợp mà giá trị xác định mà
làm cho một khoảng bạn hiểu Hiếu ạ làm
trong một khoảng nhá thì ví dụ ở đây là
gì ạ Cái bảng xếp loại đi đó làm cho một
khoản ví dụ trong khoảng từ 0 đến 5 thì
lại Biển trung bình đúng không Đấy thì
mình sẽ tìm là cái phạm vi Tìm kiếm
người sẽ tìm là kết quả một Tức là mình
sẽ tìm kiếm tương đối nhá đây làm trung
bình là trong khoảng từ 5 đến 6
ở đây là khoảng Còn nếu như mà các bạn
dùng các hàm ít như cái bài số 5 đấy Mà
Cọ xếp loại ở đây mà theo cây nguyên tắc
này thì có rất là nhiều hoặc ít đều nhau
là chí phải Nếu nhỏ Long thì yếu là
những 6 lần ngón 7 nhóm tao đấy rất là
nhiều hạt mít giống nhau đấy là cái cách
mà các bạn có thể dùng làm ít mà nhiều
bạn hãy dùng nhé Thì mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn là cái cách dùng viên cao cấp
rất là đơn giản không để làm những việc
này mà các bạn tránh phải dùng cái Hà
mít làm bạn rất là nhiều lần trong
trường hợp mà các bạn muốn xếp loạn đấy
thì trong các ví dụ này là tiện mình
muốn xếp loại cái họ tên ở đây dựa vào
điểm trung bình nhá Nếu như là gì từ 0
đến 5 thì là loại yếu này từ 5 đến 6 là
trung bình từ 6 đến 7 giờ chúng mình khá
đấy cái chắc nó ở bên này Ở đây các bạn
sẽ thích và cái ô gì oc4 Các bạn sẽ bằng
bằng cái lúc cấp các bạn tác thì cái giá
trị mà còn cần tìm kiếm là gì Là cái
biệt trung bình ở đây tức là đẹp Tôi cần
tìm kiếm cái điểm trung bình là 5.9 này
đúng không phải tiếp theo là diện là cái
Ừ rồi ok mình rất thích vào cái bảng giá
trị do ở đây là cái bảng xếp loại này
nhá đấy các bạn phải tiếp theo là gì Là
cái cột trả về nếu như mà tôi tìm được
cái điện trung bình này có trả về là
diệt là cầu số 3 đúng không Từ cái điểm
trung bình nhà rồi Cô trả về là cuộc số
3 phần cuối cùng là diện là cách sạn
Viên Tìm kiếm thì cái thứ nhá ở đây mình
không thể tìm chính xác được đúng ạ Tại
vì 5.9 nó không có cái giá trị ở trong
bảng do tin này đúng không ạ 5.9 thì nó
nằm trong cái khoảng từ 5 đến 6 để cho
nên cái thành phần cuối cùng là cái phạm
vi Tìm kiếm các bạn phải là một hoặc bà
Chu là tìm tương đối với Ví dụ mình gõ
Chu cũng được đấy các bạn xem đóng lại
để các enter thì nó sẽ trả về cái quả gì
ạ đây trả về kết quả được xếp loại đây
là từ 0 đến 5 thì bạn thích nước vào đây
mình sửa thì những lúc này cái cột trả
về không phải là cuộc số 3 là cầu số 2
Đấy cái cột nốt lại là mình ghi chú gọi
enter đợi thì nó sẽ trả về trung bình
đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ thích lúc nhá
Còn chú ý bây giờ còn tinh lúc nó sẽ bị
báo lỗi ở một số trường hợp
Ừ lát nữa mình sẽ chết cho các bạn này
còn thích nút bên đấy Bạn thấy chứ ba
cái trường hợp này nó sẽ báo lỗi tại vì
sao Bởi cậu sẽ tiếp bước vào đây còn
thấy đấy thì các bạn xếp loại nó sẽ bị
dịch xuống đây thấy tại sao nó lại bị
dịch tại vì mình áp dụng với công thức
này cho các cái ô dưới này thì khi mà
các bạn áp dụng công thức cho các ống
giấy này ạ thì cái phạm vi Tìm kiếm nó
sẽ bị dịch chuyển theo thì như vậy là gì
ạ Cái công thức ban đầu mình phải cố
định được cái phạm vi Tìm kiếm cơ đấy
như vậy là cái công thức ban đầu mình
chưa cố định phạm vi Tìm kiếm thế là
mình chưa có đô la trước các bạn vi Tìm
kiếm cho nên nó sẽ bị dịch chuyển lại họ
sẽ tích và cái ô C4 này để còn sửa công
thức nhé các bạn Facebook với ô C4 này
Bây giờ cậu sẽ Model Cái gì ạ từ E 4:10
là sau đó các bạn F4 nhá để diện để cố
định cái bảng giá trị do này sau khi các
bạn ở F4 còn thấy chứ cái chuyện Donal
nó sẽ trước hàng sẽ cột của các phạm vi
này nếu như bạn nào mà bấm F4 không được
thì các sẽ bấm cái tăng sức F4 nhá các
bạn enter rồi Bây giờ con sẽ thích Bữa
nay còn thương Tĩnh buộc cô
Ừ đợi thì như vậy Gì ạ Các Cái ô này đã
đúng rồi nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ kết thúc ở
đây còn kiểm tra lại đấy Cái phạm vi Tìm
kiếm lúc này nó sẽ cố định không bị di
chuyển phải tại vì ở đây mình đã có cái
đôla chứa kháng của chiếc cầu rồi đúng
không đấy còn chửi nhá tất cả cái vùng
tham chiếu tới à Cái bảng giá trị rò thì
các bạn phải cố định nó cho mình nhá Tại
vì sao Hầu như các công thức của mình
mình được áp dụng cho các cái ô khác
nhau cho nên cái bảng giá trị do các bạn
cần phải cố định bằng cách là các bạn sẽ
bấm phím tắt này F4 nhá Đấy là cái hết
sức lưu ý cho mình Đây là cái cách để
các ứng dụng các hàm Vlookup trong
trường hợp này mình tìm gần đúng nhá các
bạn chui Nhát Để làm được cái việc này
còn chú ý cho mình là gì ạ Cái điện
trung bình có phải sắp xếp giữa từ nhỏ
đến lớn lại Nếu như các bạn sắp xếp từ
lớn đến nhỏ là các bạn không ra đâu bây
giờ ví dụ các bạn sắp xếp từ lớn đến nhỏ
nhá bạn Bôi đen này các bạn sẽ vào cái
thẻ data Các bạn cứ làm cho mình đi các
bạn sẽ sắp xếp từ Z đến nhà cá thích vào
đây sau này mình sẽ giới thiệu một số
các thủ thuật sau nhé Hãy chọn ở đây đấy
Bạn thấy chứ gì
Ma Kết quả đây tôi sẽ báo lỗi ngay đấy
cho nên nhờ là gì ạ là cái điện trung
bình ở đây các bạn phải sắp xếp từ nhỏ
đến lớn Bây giờ mình sẽ lưu lại để bạn
thấy chứ Kết quả là ok rồi nhé Gọi chú
nhắc cái hàm Vlookup nó có một số các
nhược điểm là nhược điểm là gì ạ là cái
các bạn cần tìm kiếm có phải làm ở bên
phải giá trị dò tìm tức là gì ạ Mình
đang cần tìm cái ngày tuyển dụng đấy dựa
vào cái họ tên đúng không Thì cái ngày
tuyển dụng nó phải làm ở bên phải của
cái trường họ tên ở đây nhưng nếu như
cái họ tên đi mà nó làm sau cái ngày
tuyển dụng hoặc là lương Tức là ví dụ nó
làm ở cuối cùng một đây thì các bạn
không thể dùng cái góc cấp được rồi lúc
đấy các bạn buộc phải dùng cái hàm index
đồng nát thì cái hàm index và mét này
mình sẽ giới thiệu trong các bài học sau
là cái bài học về các hàm Excel quan
trọng khác nhá Đợi thì trong phạm vi của
wh lúc cao Hôm nay thì mình sẽ không
giới thiệu cách hàm index và Mít Ok Bây
giờ mình sẽ xem cái câu hỏi về nhà của
cái bài tập hôm nay là về W
đi câu hỏi Ok câu hỏi cho bài tập về nhà
là như sau ngã ở đây mình có biểu giá
phòng Đây là loại Phòng đây là đơn giá
tuần và đơn giản này Bây giờ các bạn cần
xác định cho mình nó được ra tuần là bao
nhiêu và đơn giản này của các loại Phòng
là bao nhiêu nhé tương tự với hạt nước
khác cũng vậy nha ở đây mình có các loại
phòng là được bố trí theo hàng ngang thì
các bạn cần xác định cho mình đã đứng ra
quần là bao nhiêu và đơn giản này là bao
nhiêu đấy câu hỏi về nhà nó cũng đơn
giản như vậy thôi Ok như vậy là mình đã
kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm
ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng
ký Kênh để cập nhật video mới nhất của
gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người
cùng học Excel nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp
lại ở